-Our next guest is a very
funny comedian you know
from shows such as
"High Maintenance" and "Shrill."
His new half hour,
"Carmen Christopher"
Street Special,"
is streaming now on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-If I was a teacher,
no bathroom breaks.
We're here to learn,
not pee and poo.
[ Horn honks ]
I'm excited to say
that I got through most
of my goals this year,
except for my summer
reading list,
which was the Bible,
"A Bridge to Terabithia,"
and the
"From Dusk Till Dawn" DVD case
Yeah. Sorry.
Just trying to bring joy
to New York.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome to the sho
Carmen Christopher, everybody.
[ Applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Thanks for being here, buddy
I really appreciate it.
-Thanks for having me, Seth.
Thanks for having me.
♪♪♪♪
Wow.
-So, Carmen, I'm thrilled
to have you here,
but you have, in fact,
been here before.
You are friendly with a bunc
of the writers on the show
and you have done bits
on this show.
Here's one. Do you remember what
you were doing in this sketch?
-Yes.
This is a character.
His name is Little Bobo
and he pranks dogs.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I think was written
by Conner O'Malley
and possibly Seth and Ben, too
-Yeah. Yeah.
The great Conner O'Malley.
Oh, you guys
have collaborated before
and this is one
of your finest pieces of work.
-I think so.
You guys let me have fun,
but there was some
structure to it
and that's entertainment
for you.
[ Laughter ]
-This is, obviously,
a very unique special,
sort of inspired, I guess,
or necessitated,
out of the pandemic,
but you decided to go out
and do stand-up in the street.
-Yes. Yes. So, basically,
I was like, "Ooh, pandemic
I got to take this opportunity
and do something with it."
And, honestly, that's probably
a bad way to say that.
But the idea was I had
this stand-up material
and I wanted to burn it
because I was like,
"I don't want
to do this material
once the pandemic's over."
I was kind of sick of it.
So I was like, "Why don't we
just go film it on the streets?"
Most of my comedy is
embarrassing myself,
so I was like, "Why don't we add
an extra layer to it
and go do this
on the streets of New York?"
-And so one thing I notice
from the clip
and from watching the special is
the speaker is very good,
but it looks very heavy.
-Yeah, that speaker's like -
it's got to be 75 pounds.
[ Laughter ]
And also, that speaker was $250,
which is like, you know,
basically, it's like
if this doesn't turn
into a special,
it's like that's just sad
and I should quit comedy.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what I mean?
-Right. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-So this is great, that sort o
Peacock came to the rescue
and got you that speaker money
-I got to think Peacock.
Shout-out to Peacock,
everybody over there.
Mike DiCenzo brought it
to them, thankfully,
and they said,
"Let's give it a go,"
and it's the first origina
comedy special on Peacock,
so check it out, yeah.
One of the groups of peopl
that you approach a fair amoun
in the special are diners.
-Yes.
-So people are taking advantag
of the outdoor dining
that we sort of saw
this last year.
How were they? Did they like
that you sort of came over
or were they
on the other side of that?
-Most people ignored me, but
a lot of people didn't like it
Actually --
So there was one guy
who actually threatened
to throw a glass bottle at m
because I did this joke.
It's not like a great joke
I don't even want to say it now,
but I will.
[ Laughter ]
It was basically,
"What's with these AirPods
It's like,
right when you open them,
they pretty much disintegrat
into the air.
-[ Laughs ]
I'd have a better job
tracking down a booger that
flicked in the fourth grade.
And he was with his family
and he didn't like that
and so he threatened
to throw a bottle at me
and I said, "If you throw this
bottle at me, I'll sue you."
-[ Laughs ]
-So, you know, you can tel
that, you know, I'm tough.
-[ Laughing ] Right.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's a good response
to a heckler,
like to threaten
legal ramifications.
-I honestly think
that stopped him
from throwing the bottle at me
because, then, he just
sprinkled water on me.
-Oh, so he held the bottle
but did the water.
-Yeah, he did that
and I said, "Oh, tough,"
and then, we were good.
-And, like the clip,
how often would people
at the actual establishments
come out and ask you to stop
-I think probably like
only like three
or four times, honestly,
but we put them all
in the special
because we wanted
to make it look
as depressing as possible.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Like there were people --
Like we did shoot
and there were people
who like cheered and liked it,
but we didn't really want
to show that.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's better to not
you know.
-Now, I think anyone
who doesn't do comedy
for a living would say,
"I could never imagine
getting up in a comedy club,
and, yet, at least people
in a comedy club
wanted to watch comedy.
-Yeah.
-By buying a ticket or by going,
they said,
"We're up for comedy."
Now, obviously,
you didn't have that situation
Did that make it more stressfu
for you or less stressful?
-It was awful.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I
wouldn't recommend it
to anybody.
So many times,
while we were shooting,
I said to myself,
"I'll never do this again.
I'll never do this again."
Yeah, it was really, really bad.
[ Laughs ]
-And, yet, is it still
better than --
I know you previously
had a job in sales.
-Oh boy.
Yeah, yeah.
I worked
in sales for eight years.
I was doing sales
for the first four years
and then,
the last four years of it,
I was also juggling
doing comedy.
But the job was great
because it taught me busines
and it taught me
customer service
and how to talk
to people and stuff.
But it was
for a logistics company
and, as you can imagine,
it's kind of boring.
But what was the question?
[ Laughter ]
-Just, you know.
You know, I feel like this is --
I feel like everybody
can retrofit the question
they feel like that did
the best job answering.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I don't --
-I mean, I feel like,
obviously, the show --
there is a great amount
of logistics to the show,
just moving that speaker around.
-Yeah, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah, like planning where to go.
We did, we had
an executive producer.
So, basically, there were
three people in the crew.
There was Danny Scharar,
who directed and edited;
there was Harris Mayersohn
who was the executive producer
and Matt Nelsen,
second camera operator.
That was the team.
It was just us three
and Harris kind of planned
where we were going to go,
this and that, and he was
the logistics coordinator
and I got the day off.
-Oh, wow. Nicely done.
Is your family, by nature,
a comic group of people?
-Everybody's funny,
but they don't try to be.
They're just like wild,
you know?
But I would say that
the funniest person, to me
was probably my grandfather.
His name's Benny
and he was missing
his index finger.
He actually lost it while he was
working in a warehouse.
And, anytime you'd ask him
how he lost his finger,
he had a completely
different story.
So, he's from Mexico,
so he had an accent.
I'm not going to do the accent
because, you know.
But I'd be like, "Grandpa,
how'd you lose your finger?"
And he was like,
"I was really hungry
and I bit into my sandwich
and I ate it."
-[ Laughs ]
-Another time, I was like,
"Grandpa, how'd you lose
your finger?"
And he's like, "Your grandma
was talking too much,
so I told her to shh,
and she bit it."
-[ Laughs ]
-And, another time, he sai
that he was at war
and someone shot at him
and he went
to go stop the bullet,
so he went like this
[ Laughter ]
and his finger exploded.
-That's pretty good times.
-He's funny, man.
-Also I'm very happy,
especially after watching
your special,
that you are going to be bac
doing an actual
indoor comedy show.
-Yeah.
-When's your first show?
-I'm doing, actually,
a show that's
on my birthday, June 20th --
also Father's Day --
at the Bell House.
The show is called "El Juice
(Formerly The Juice)."
I had to change it
for legal purposes.
-Really, they wouldn't
let you do "The Juice"?
-Well, there's a different sho
that has a similar name
that was like, "We're goin
to do a cease and desist"...
-Oh, excellent.
-...so I changed it
to "El Juice."
-Very crafty. I mean, I thin
-Thank you.
-that is, again, logistics
-Yeah, yeah.
-You know business,
you know logistics.
"El Juice,"
you're out of trouble.
-These are some
great compliments.
-[ Laughs ]
-Thank you. I appreciate that.
-Congratulations, for real
on the special.
-Oh, wow. Yeah.
-It's really great. And thanks
for being here in person.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
This is so fun.
-"Carmen Christopher:
Street Special."
It's streaming now on Peacock.
It's fantastic.